Syrian dictator Bashar Assad uses
chemical weapons again London talks
about banning knives yes really and the
Atlantic bans conservatives I'm Ben
Shapiro and this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so welcome back here we are in our
beautiful Studios once again and I could
not be more pleased to be home except
for how I wish our on vacation still but
since I am NOT we will have to do a show
so I have a lot to talk about today
obviously the possibility of war in the
Middle East is heating up in pretty
dramatic fashion after Bashar Assad used
chemical weapons on his own citizens but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Birch gold so the stock
market has been up and down and up and
down and up and down and up and down I
mean it's been extraordinarily volatile
over the past several weeks this is one
of the reasons why it makes sense to
have some of your money in precious
metals I'm not saying take all your
money out of the stock market and put it
in precious metals I don't have a lot of
my money in the stock market but I do
have a certain percentage of my earnings
in precious metals and the reason for
that is because I don't want the
government manipulated in currency and I
want to hedge against that and also the
stock market is quite volatile right now
and that means that if you want to hedge
against the problems of volatility Gold
is not a bad way to do that well with
all of that uncertainty that means that
you should trust my friends over at
Birch gold group if you do decide to
invest in precious metals they have a
long-standing track record of continued
success with thousands of satisfied
clients counts countless five-star
reviews and an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau contact Birch gold group
right now and request a free information
kit on physical precious metals this
comprehensive 16 page kit shows how gold
and silver can protect your savings and
how you can if you seek to do so legally
move your IRA or 401k out of stocks and
bonds and into precious metals IRA to
get that no-cost no-obligation kit go to
www.hsn
that's birchgold.com slash pen they're
good people they're trustworthy people
ask all of your questions make sure that
you have all your answers and then talk
to my friends over at Birch gold that's
birchgold.com / Ben get that free
information kit and that also lets them
know that we sent you okay so obviously
the big news over the weekend and the
big news today is the situation in Syria
so over the last few days the dictator
of Syria used chemical weapons against
his own citizens once again and the
footage broke on TV now as you recall
the last time there was a public use of
chemical weapons and the news broke on
TV president Trump lobbed a couple of
missiles into Syria it is something like
50 missiles were lobbed into Syria and
in a particular airbase was hit well
it's unclear what exactly the United
States is going to do as of yet but all
the action has been taken it's been
taken by Israel so Israel went in and
and knocked out a Syrian Air Base and
took down some of their Syrian air
defenses and I'll give you all that
information in just a second for those
who don't know what Syrian chemical
weapons attacks look like they are just
horrendous and horrific the footage
looked something like this so you can
see these children are you know being
treated they're being washed off with
water because they've all been doused
with chemical weapons a lot of these a
lot of these folks are have died of
suffocation some of the 100 people died
of suffocation and the I mean these are
children these are small children so
obviously we see images like this it's
absolutely horrific Israel lashed out
yesterday so here's the story from The
Associated Press Russia and the Syrian
military have blamed Israel for a
pre-dawn missile attack Monday on a
Syrian Air Base that reportedly killed
14 people including through iranian x'
while international condemnation grew
over a suspected poison gas attack over
the weekend that was said to be carried
out by the Syrian government opposition
activists said 40 people died in the
chemical attack blaming President Bashar
Assad's forces the UN Security Council
plans to hold an emergency meeting
Monday to discuss the chemical attack
well whoop-dee-do with the UN Security
Council Russia sits on the UN Security
Council Russia is the great sponsors
state of the Syrian regime so nothing is
going to happen in the UN Security
Council we should put all of our money
from that awful institution if you want
know how terrible the UN is understand
that Syria is about to sit on the
committee for the regulation of chemical
and biological weapons no that is not a
joke that is a real actual thing so
before you start thinking that the UN is
gonna step in and solve anything at all
recognize that the UN is a gigantic joke
and that is why it's up to sovereign
states to do something about these sort
of atrocities the timing of the strike
on the airbase in the central homs
province hours after President Trump
said there would be a big price to pay
for the chemical weapons attack raised
questions about whether Israel is acting
alone or as a proxy for the United
States Israel typically does not comment
on its airstrikes in Syria
it was the second such attack this year
on the air base the air base is known as
t4 and it's where Iranian fighters are
believed to be stationed according to
Russia's Defense Ministry two Israeli
aircraft targeted the t4 Air Base firing
eight missiles it said Syria shot down
five of them the other three landed in
the West
part of the base syrian state TV quoted
an unnamed military official saying that
israeli f-15 were planes fired several
missiles at t4 and it gave no further
details and of course israel's foreign
ministry said nothing since 2012
israel has struck inside syria more than
100 times mostly targeting suspected
weapons convoys destined for the
Lebanese militant group Hezbollah which
has been fighting along Syrian
governmental forces so this looks like
this could be the prelude to larger
action John McCain and one of the people
Senator McCain has been pushing for a
larger action in Syria for a long time
he's wanted to topple the Syrian regime
for years and years and he suggested
that we armed Syrian rebels one of the
problems with that at the time as he
wasn't clear who the Syrian rebels
actually were were they all kind gentle
nice people were some of them associated
with terrorist groups the way that some
of the people we armed in Libya were
that was unclear at the time it led to a
lot of Republican pushback here's what
Senator McCain had to say he said
President Trump last week signal to the
world that the United States would
prematurely withdraw from Syria we never
chance to talk about this last week but
Trump did say he wanted to withdraw from
Syria and immediately within days Bashar
Assad was using chemical weapons on his
own citizens that's why President
Trump's rhetoric actually matters and to
pretend otherwise is foolish McCain
continues Bashar Assad and his Russian
and Iranian backers have heard him and
emboldened by American inaction Assad
has reportedly launched another chemical
attack against innocent men women and
children this time in Duma initial
accounts show dozens of innocent
civilians including children have been
targeted by this vicious bombardment
designed to burn and choke the human
body and leave victims writhing in
unspeakable pain crimes against humanity
who become Assad's trademarks in his
relentless campaign against the people
of Syria that has killed more than half
a million people enforced 11 million
people from their homes according to
John McCain president Trump was quick to
call out Assad today along with the
Russian and Iranian government's on
Twitter the question now is whether he
will do anything about it the president
responded decisively when Assad used
chemical weapons last year he should do
so again and demonstrate that Assad will
pay a price for his war crimes to be
sure president Trump inherited bad
options after years of in actions by his
predecessor in Syria history will render
a bitter judgment on America for that
failure but no one should believe that
we are out of options we can and should
change course starting with a
comprehensive strategy that lays out
clear objectives for our mission there
well that is the big question is what
are the objectives going to be for the
mission there because a foreign policy
isolationist people like Ann Coulter or
Rand Paul they would say we have no
interest in Syria whatsoever so terrible
things are
happening there awful humanitarian
crisis but humanitarian crises are
happening all over the world that is not
the job of the United States to stop
every humanitarian crisis it all depends
on the sort of blood and treasure
America will have to expend in order to
stop those humanitarian crises well
that's obviously true we have to
calculate each individual situation on
its own but the situation on Syria has
fundamentally changed in the several
years since President Obama allowed
Bashar Assad to get away with his
chemical weapons attack here's what
President Trump tweeted after all of the
after the chemical weapons attack he
tweeted quote many dead including women
and children and mindless chemical
attack in Syria area of atrocity is in
lockdown and encircled by Syrian army
making it completely inaccessible to
outside world
President Putin Russia and Iran are
responsible for backing animal Assad so
he's now have gotten a nickname for
Assad which is entirely appropriate in
this case big price and continued big
price to pay open area immediately for
medical help and verification another
humanitarian disaster for no reason
whatsoever sick ok all of that is true
the question becomes okay what is going
to happen next well Trump's national
security adviser while his security
advisors rather Tombaugh surd's he was
on national TV on Sunday and he said
listen all the options are on the table
here one of those issues on which every
nation all peoples have all agreed and
have agreed since World War two is an
unacceptable practice so well they there
will be another missile attack yeah I
wouldn't take anything off the table
these are horrible photos we're looking
into the attack at this point the State
Department put out a statement last
night and the president senior national
security cabinet had been talking with
him and with each other all throughout
the evening and this morning and myself
included so one of the things that's
amazing about all of this is that people
on the Left are already critical of
Trump Trump inherited an awful situation
here Tommy Vietor who is just a dolt he
used to drive a van for Obama then
suddenly ended up as a National Security
Council or for President Obama after
driving a van and now I guess that he is
and now I guess that he is doing pod
save America type stuff well he tweeted
out that President Trump inherited a bad
situation
well Tommy who did he inherit that from
weren't you there I mean all you were
there at the time now there were those
of us who opposed President Obama's
quote-unquote pinpricks strike in Syria
the reason being that if you send a
missile into Syria and then you do
nothing else you actually embolden the
Iranians and you emboldened the Syrians
and you
in the Russians nobody expected that
President Obama was going to give away
the store to the Russians if recall back
to 2013 Bashar Assad used chemical
weapons Barack Obama then drew a red
line in the sand here is President Obama
back then drawing the red line we have
been very clear to the Assad regime but
also to other players on the ground that
a red line for us is we start seeing a
whole bunch of chemical weapons moving
around or being utilized that would
change my calculus that would change my
equation okay so he made that statement
actually in August of 2012 then of
course Bashar Assad immediately used
chemical weapons like within a couple of
months and then Barack Obama did
something really unexpected first he
said maybe I'll maybe I'll throw a
missile in there but you know what I
need congressional approval now that was
obviously a lie because he didn't have
congressional approval for his Libya
action he just went ahead and did it but
he he said I'll throw it to Congress and
that went nowhere and then he said you
know what I'll let the Russians take
over the Russians can come in and they
will disarm this year in so Barack Obama
and Susan Rice both came out Susan Rice
then the national security adviser she
came out and she said don't worry
Syria's chemical weapons have been
removed they're gone Syria has no more
chemical weapons ready the Obama was
triumphalist about this he said
everything is better there will be no
more chemical chemical weapons attacks
everything is under control here is
Barack Obama and Susan Rice this is back
in 2013 we've done these last eight
years without firing a shot we've
eliminated Syria's declared chemical
weapons program all of these steps have
helped to keep us safe and helped to
keep our troops safe
[Music]
those are the result of diplomacy we
don't have strong efforts there the more
you will be called upon to clean up
after the failure of diplomacy we were
able to find a solution that actually
removed the chemical weapons that were
known from Syria in a way that the use
of force would never have accomplished
okay and Tommy meters have the same
thing well you know we got rid of a lot
of the chemical weapons right except for
the ones that he's using on the
civilians and has continued to use on
the civilians so well done Susan Rice is
amazing all these people who came into
the Obama administration proclaiming
that it was a new day for American
foreign policy and they're gonna act in
the humanitarian interest of the people
of Syria and then proceeded to allow
that entire country to descend into
utter and absolute chaos now there's a
civil war going on and that wasn't
Barack Obama's fault it was Barack
Obama's fault that he decided to hand
over all of these security concerns to
the Russians the Russians obviously had
nefarious purposes they're all they care
about is propping up Bashar Assad and
all of this raises the question which is
okay what should the United States do
now and that is a serious and open
question you know it is amazing again
how badly the Obama administration blew
it this is not on President Trump but
now Trump is the president so that
raises a question as to where we go from
here in a second I'm going to answer
that question for you
or at least give you maybe some some
concerns that I have about full-scale
military intervention as well as some
possibilities on what we can do in Syria
right now first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over at stamps.com so these
days you can get practically everything
on demand but you still think you have
to go to the post office to get your
stamps well you no longer have to go to
your post office to get the stamps
instead you go to stamps calm with
stamps calm you can access all of the
amazing services of the post office
right from your desk 24/7 when it's
convenient for you buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package using your own computer and
printer the mail carrier just picks it
up just click print mail you're not you
can print it right on to the envelope
you can print it right onto a sticker
you can print it right onto a piece of
paper and then tape it to an envelope we
use stamps calm here at the Daily wire
offices all the time because we don't
have time to run down to the post office
it saves us time it saves us money and
it will save you time and money as well
right now we have a special offer for
all of our listeners if you use a promo
code
Shapiro's you get fifty five bucks up to
fifty five bucks of free postage plus a
digital scale and a four week trial so
all you do is go to stamps calm and
before you do anything else before
even check out the website click on the
radio microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro and that
can see that's your promo code stamps
comm use that promo code Shapiro and
again you get up to fifty five dollars
free postage a digital scale and a
four-week trial so pretty spectacular
deal once you've tried it you'll love it
and you'll continue using it I promise
stamps calm and use that promo code
Shapiro when you click on that radio
microphone at the top of the page again
that radio microphone click ship hero
type in Shapiro get that special deal
and let them know that we sent you okay
so what exactly should we do from here
right that is the big question in all of
this and one of the things that has
changed you there are a lot of people
like me who back during the Obama
administration said this a direct quote
in 2013 lobbing missiles into Syria
without decapitating the regime
strengthens both both Assad and the
mullahs in other words whatever you do
has to have real impact you can't do
what Obama wanted to do and take a
half-assed action and then hope that
everything is gonna be better that
doesn't work you can't hover a hand over
power to the Russian government whose
only interest is in continued
propagation of the domination of Bashar
Assad and the continued domination of
the Iranian regime across the Middle
East and things have changed radically
since 2013 it because of a couple of
deals that the Obama administration cut
remember the situation in 2012-2013 was
a lot simpler Russia was not running
Syria at that point in Iran was still
under American sanction well because of
Barack Obama Iran now has a lot of money
to play with and they have expanded
their terrorism outreach all across the
Middle East suddenly there's a swath of
territory all the way from Iran to
Lebanon that is dominated by Iran that's
dominated by ur and that includes Syria
this is why Israel was the one that
actually struck out yesterday at this at
the targets in Syria they've been
striking out at targets in Syria as I
say over a hundred times they struck at
targets in Syria since 2012 because
Syria is being used as a thoroughfare
for the world's worst weapons being put
in the hands of terrorists people like
Hamas people like Hezbollah yea glean a
MOS is a general retired general in the
Israeli Army's the executive director of
Tel Aviv University's Institute for
national security studies and is a
really interesting tweet thread about
what happened last night when Israel
apparently struck t4 which is in a
Syrian air base he said the reported
strike last night in T for Syria is part
of the two colliding vectors Iranian
determination to entrench itself in
Syria and Israeli resolve to prevent it
this was the first reported air strike
since
since February 10th incidents the
colliding vectors were recognized months
ago in the Israeli national security
strategy and Syrian and Iranian
responses cannot be ruled out this
strikes timing drove Syria to first
distribute it to the US as a response to
Assad's use of chemical weapons against
civilians in Duma however the US has
denied responsibility while the target
hit is connected to Iran and not to and
not to chemical weapons it is not from
t4a air air force base that the CW
dropping aircraft came while reports of
Iranian casualties are a strong
testament that being said a strike may
well serve two purposes promoting two
objectives in a single step preventing
Iranian and transmen in Syria with
advanced weaponry and sending a moral
message that using CW to commit mass
murder is not acceptable to that end
even if it does not take responsibility
for the strike last night it is
important that Israel make its voice
heard denouncing the use of chemical
weapons and their use in Syria a way to
u.s. and Western response and one cannot
rule out the possibility of us strike on
regime targets so here's what's
happening this has now become a grand
strategic game this is no longer a
situation in which everything is
contained okay that's the reality of the
situation in Syria right now this is not
a containable situation Russia is
involved Iran is involved this is now a
proxy war about who is going to control
this entire swath of land in the Middle
East that means tau D Arabia is involved
it means Jordan is involved it means
Egypt is involved
it means Israel is involved if World War
three breaks out in Syria World War
three will break out because Barack
Obama allowed Syria to become a
tinderbox by pulling American troops out
of Iraq by allowing Iran to run
roughshod through Iraq and by allowing
Iran to extend its domination all the
way to Lebanon so what exactly should we
do and we should do a couple of things
if we have the capacity we should knock
out as much of the Syrian air force as
we possibly can
we should knock down as many of their
anti-aircraft missiles as we possibly
can
we should it's probably impossible to
decapitate the regime with significant
amounts of boots on the ground whatever
we can do from the air we should do from
the air and we should also ensure that
there are safe havens safe havens for
Syrian rebels and people who want to
escape the Assad regime and those should
be protected by a coalition force led by
the United States the reason being that
there have to be safe spaces for all of
these Syrian refugees otherwise they're
just going to come into the West
otherwise they're just going to escape
across the Mediterranean and into Europe
or they will come to the United States
and that is something that
from supporters are not fond of either
so the either they're gonna stay there
and save places that we helped set up or
they will be killed or they will escape
but should we go in and make this a
full-scale land war probably not
probably not because again what's
America's interest here America has two
real interests chuckin Russian ambitions
well three interests okay humanitarian
but that exists all across the globe
checking Russian interests in Syria
Russia wants to ensure the Prashar Assad
and the Iranian regime retain power and
gain power in that region which makes it
more likely the war breaks out and
stopping the growth of the Iranian
regime Israel in Saudi Arabia by the way
are happy to take the lead here right
Israel obviously is already taking the
lead here is rosin gonna wait so the
fact that the United States can mobilize
a commitment behind Israeli LED action
in Syria would be a good thing if we
have allies who are willing to do this
there's no reason the United States
should have to lead the way but again
the u.s. is going to have to be involved
that means setting up these these safer
places for Syrian refugees to go it
means neutering the ability of the Assad
regime to use chemical weapons and it
means preventing them from making more
territorial encroachments into
rebel-held areas and that means
providing actual armed support to
whatever Syrian rebels are left who have
not been murdered already by Isis and
the Assad regime and arming those people
who are left in order to resist the
Assad regime this now has implications
far beyond the borders of Syria and we
are gonna pay a price for it in terms of
money and treasure and the possibility
of additional terrorism and the spread
of chemical weapons if we take a fully
hands-off approach as some of the more
isolationist members of the Republican
Party seem to be seem to be promoting
okay well meanwhile there's there's a
bunch of other stuff going on among
those other things apparently President
Trump is intent on launching a trade war
the stock market has been up and down
basically assuming that you know
President Trump is not serious about the
trade war or that he is serious about
the trade war it's not clear where he is
on the trade war but it's interesting to
see how many members of the oh how many
members of the Trump administration are
trying to kind of shift his thinking on
trade itself so let's talk a little bit
about where he is so a couple of Trump's
officials went on TV over the weekend to
talk about president Trump's initiation
of a trade war against China
he obviously has set tariffs
extraordinarily high in particular
sectors of the economy and there are two
takes on tariffs they take number one
from the Trump administration on tariffs
is that tariffs are a tool that is to be
used as often as possible because
they're good for the United States we
have a trade deficit and the only way to
rectify that trade imbalance is to put
tariffs on foreign products thereby
forcing American citizens to buy
American and lowering the amount of
money that we are exporting to China for
example okay that is idiotic
economically for reasons that I've
suggested many times on this program
okay the reality is the taxing American
citizens does not make American citizens
more wealthy and all the tariffs is is
an indirect tax on American citizens for
the benefit of certain American
businesses so if there is a CO maker who
is less efficient than another steel
maker that is located abroad and you are
forcing American citizens to patronize
the American steel maker you are taking
money out of my pocket and giving it to
another business that is just a form of
redistribution ISM it's a tax-and-spend
program that's all a tariff is it's a
domestic tax-and-spend program and that
does not make America any wealthier now
it is another question if you are using
trade in order to punish bad regimes for
example and we've done that with South
Africa in the past we have done that
with Iran we did that that's what
sanctions were for it was essentially a
tariff on on an impossibly high tariff
on Iran was essentially what a sanction
is in policy right so there's using it
for security reasons there's also using
it in order to try and job other
countries to lower their tariffs so
let's say China has a bunch of tariffs
on American products and we say listen
you lower your tariffs will lower our
tariffs but if you're gonna terrify our
products we will tariffs yours in our
market is bigger than yours alright then
that may be worthwhile also now the
problem here is that Trump is a devotee
of the first kind of thinking the
tariffs are universally good a lot of
the people who surround him are people
who think that tariffs can be
strategically useful and I think what
they are trying to do inside the Trump
administration is manipulate the
president into using tariffs as a
targeted method of lowering tariffs
elsewhere or pushing security change and
what Trump actually wants he just likes
the tariffs generally so you can see
this from some of his officials Steve
minuchin is one of them
my nutrient came out and he said listen
maybe there'll be a trade war but it'll
be okay Trump what Trump's officials
know better than anybody the people who
surround Trump is that there's one word
Trump does not hear and that word is
know if you say the president Trump know
about anything there is a 100% guarantee
he will do that thing and does no matter
what the thing is literally they told
him don't walk into a solar eclipse
without your sunglasses and the
President of the United States took
office and
glasses and looked into a solar eclipse
because if you tell him no he's got the
same reaction and both my kids who are
you who are you okay so Steve minuchin
and Larry Kudlow both have been avoiding
telling him no what they're trying to do
instead is I think convince him that
it's a qualified no yes mr. president
that's brilliant policy but who best if
you used it in this particular way so
I'll explain what they're doing in just
a second first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over at wink so you know
does all this news stuff make you
stressed out it makes me stressed out
and that's why at night sometimes you
need a glass of wine let's be real about
this or you're going over to a dinner
party and you don't know anything about
wine and you don't want to arrive at
their door with a bottle of Drano well
the best way to avoid that horrible fate
is to go over my friends at wink
so wink mezack makes it easy to discover
great wine winks wine experts select
wines matched to your taste personalized
for you shipped right to your door
starting just 13 bucks a bottle
it just fill out Winx palate profile
quiz so here's how it works you go and
there's a bunch of simple questions
things like how do you take your coffee
how do you feel about blueberries taste
that you like and then they will
recommend a bottle of wine to you and
they send wines curate it's your taste
more wines you rate the more
personalized your monthly selections
become it's just like any other service
like Netflix they have the algorithms
that help them determine what kind of
wines you will like and each month there
are new delicious wines right now they
have an insanely popular summer water
rose a this wine is very popular around
the office we've actually had wink wine
tastings here at the office which is not
good for productivity but it is good for
a company spirits they discover great
wine today go to try wink calm slash Ben
it's winc calm try wink calm slash Ben
you get 20 bucks off your first shipment
that's t ry winc calm / Ben for $20 off
your first shipment again try wink calm
slash Ben their wines are all tremendous
and you will really enjoy them and again
they all curated directly to your tastes
you never have to arrive at somebody's
house for the crappy bottle of wine ever
again nor do you have to spend a hundred
bucks on a nice bottle of wine just to
prove that you know what you're doing
instead go to try winked calm / Ben and
you get that twenty bucks off that also
wants to know that we sent you ok so
here are the members of the Trump
administration trying to convince
President Trump that a trade war might
not be a bad idea well saying well ok
maybe there'll be a trade war because
they don't actually want to say no to
the president here's steve minuchin the
treasury secretary i don't expect there
will be a trade war it could be but i
don't i don't expect it at all but the
president
is willing to make sure we are free and
fair trade as you've seen his tweet
already this morning and again he has a
very close relationship with President
Xi and will continue to discuss these
issues with them okay so he is
soft-pedaling it because again if you
say no to Trump it is more likely that
he launches a trade war on everybody
Larry Kudlow sort of doing the same
thing he's the new head of the National
Economic Council and a free trader he
says listen we have to do this but
listen to his rationale for why these
tariffs are necessary it is not because
the tariffs are a great idea just in and
of themselves it's because he thinks
that they are a useful tool for lowering
tariffs elsewhere look we have to do
this we have to get China to change its
behaviour in two decades and they're
still stealing our intellectual property
they're still forcing technology
turnovers from our businesses to them
there's still got high tariffs they
still got trade barriers they still have
market closing instead of market open so
that's got a cage Trump is doing the
Lord's work
okay so Kudlow is basically saying the
tariffs are our point of leverage it's
not that tariffs are just wonderfully in
a great thing you know president Trump
however tends to think that they are a
great thing I hope that Kudlow obviously
prevails I hope that minuchin prevails I
hope that his team allows Trump to
recognize the reality about trade which
the tariffs can be a useful tool for
leveraging things from other people but
they're not good innately for the United
States of America okay meanwhile in
other news late last week I didn't get a
chance to comment on it this is an
amazing story Jeffrey Goldberg is the
editor of the Atlantic Jeffrey Goldberg
is also a schmuck so Jeffrey Goldberg is
the guy who was essentially a tool of
the Obama administration in pushing out
there Iran lies every time that a piece
of propaganda they went out to Jeffrey
Goldberg because Jeffrey Goldberg was
there boy
Jeffrey Goldberg was the guy who's gonna
say what they want well now he's the
editor of the Atlantic and a couple of
weeks ago a few weeks ago he did
something that looked a little more
reasonable it looked a little smarter he
said he wanted to diversify the opinion
pages over at the Atlantic and they
hired former National Review columnist
Kevin Williamson now Kevin is a real
iconoclast Kevin is the kind of guy who
says I would say wild things on a
regular basis he's a create he's a
tremendous writer I mean a really
tremendous writer but all of his
language is extraordinarily strong he
always takes very strong positions some
of them on
bizarre issues and one of the issues
that people had known about for a long
time the Kevin had spoken about was that
he is not generally in favor of the
death penalty he doesn't like the death
penalty and he would avoid the death
penalty but if the death penalty were to
remain applicable in the United States
he believes that women should be
punished for abortion because of
abortion is homicide then women should
be punished for it and if women were to
be punished for it and the death penalty
were still in play then he presumes that
women would get the death penalty right
he had tweeted about that before and the
Atlantic fully knew about this right
Jeffrey Goldberg know about it everyone
on Twitter knew about this it was one of
Williamson's weirder positions now the
general pro-life position on this issue
is that you wouldn't actually punish the
woman afford the abortion you punish the
abortion doctors for the abortion
because women who are obtaining
abortions generally are doing so because
they do not have the proper mens rea
they don't actually think of it as
killing their own baby and so they don't
actually know what it is they're doing
whereas the doctor full dwell knows what
he's doing this has always been the
pro-life position in the general
pro-life community Williamson takes an
even stronger position than that
obviously well he tweeted something out
about it and then they discovered that
on a podcast he talked a little bit
about it so here's what it sounded like
when Kevin Williamson this this new
Atlantic columnist had talked about this
on a podcast with with Charlie Cook
National Review podcast called mad dogs
and Englishmen and someone challenged me
on my views abortion you know saying if
you really thought it was a crime you
would support things like you know life
in prison no parole for treating some
homicide and I do support that in fact
as I wrote what I mind is hanging and
Vyasa when I was talking about Yahoo da
I would totally go with treating like
any other crime up to including hanging
okay so what he meant there of course is
that as a thought experiment if you were
going to have hanging as the legal
method of death in all of these various
areas Williamson by nature is against
the death penalty by the way then he
would say that that applies to abortion
now so I think that's a good argument
now do I do I agree with Williamson no
but the Atlantic fired him for this okay
then they issued a statement talking
about how his views were essentially
unacceptable here is what Goldberg said
quote the language he used in this
podcast and in my conversations with him
in recent days made it clear that the
original tweet did in fact represent his
carefully considered views okay well you
didn't know that like he had said that
it was known it was on his Twitter
account and I assume that Jeffrey
Goldberg had called him up about it and
go
it said do you believe this and William
said yeah I believe this well as the
editor of the website one of the things
that we do is we hire a bunch of people
with widely disparate views they're all
on the right because I am the editor of
the website and it's a right-wing
website it's conservative website over
at Daily wire if people hold opinions
like pro-choice opinions for example
they do not appear on our website there
may be pro-choice writers right for us I
really don't know but I can edit what
goes on my website well the Atlantic
certainly could have done the same thing
with Williamson if they don't like this
particular opinion he said listen I
would write a long article about why
hanging is the proper response to
abortion and the in the Atlantic listen
we don't want that in our pages that's
their prerogative but firing him
preemptively for a thought crime for a
view that he had not expressed in the
pages of the Atlantic is a pretty
amazing thing and Williamson has a lot
of very strong positions and what this
really is is that the Left believes that
any right winger it wouldn't matter it
wouldn't matter for Williamson or Bret
Stevens or me or Ross dude hat it does
not matter anybody who is on the right
Barry Weiss is not even on the white
right if you are if you are not of the
hardcore left then the left sees you as
an improper human being right they will
not allow you to appear in their pages
on a regular basis or if they do they
will do so extraordinarily grudgingly
okay and in the Atlantic was considered
a more moderate sort of publication
right there are more moderate
publications that try to do this but
they are becoming fewer and far between
and just to point out that the Atlantic
is not consistent about their standards
for public rhetoric the Atlantic
champions the fact that they are the
home of tonic EC codes tonic ICI Coates
wrote about 9/11 first responders that
they were quote-unquote not human to me
that is a direct quote from Tony he's he
quotes a ton in town he's he coats hey
the fact is that the Atlantic has given
glowing profiles to people like Peter
Singer Peter Singer is a in it is a
quote unquote ethicist at Princeton who
forcibly advocates for the murder of
children outside the womb he says if a
woman wants to kill a baby after it is
born that is okay so just to be straight
about this Peter Singer says killing a
baby after it's born is okay because
babies don't have an awareness of their
time and place in the universe because
they're stupid and so you can kill them
right this is Peter Singer stated
position on on genocide against small
children against babies that is worthy
of some sort of decent profile in the
Atlantic by Kevin Williamson is too
harsh on people who actually kill their
babies and this is consider
something just egregious and wrong and
terrible it's pretty amazing and
demonstrates the extremism of left in a
second I'm gonna explain to you why it
is that this has some pretty dramatic
ramifications for the entire political
discourse because you know Williamson
may be an iconoclastic figure you may
not know who he is you may not care
about the Atlantic but this is an
indicator of where our political
discourse is going and it is nowhere
good I have a lot of thoughts on this
first you're gonna have to go over to
daily wired icon and subscribe so for
$9.99 a month you get a subscription to
daily wire when you get that
subscription you get the rest of my show
live you have the rest of mantle Clavin
show live you get the rest of Michael
Mills show live as well and you get to
be part of my mailbag Drew's mailbag
also tomorrow is the conversation right
so our next episode of the conversation
is coming up tomorrow 5:30 Eastern 2:30
p.m. Pacific here's the way that it
works if you haven't joined the
conversation series is our monthly Q&A
it's hosted by Alicia Krauss and all the
hosts to answer personal questions all
these questions Andrew Clavin is the
victim tomorrow so you can ask all of
your questions to him it streams live at
the YouTube and Facebook pages it's free
for everybody to watch only subscribers
can actually ask the questions to ask
the questions as a subscriber log in to
our website daily wire.com head over to
the conversation page to watch the live
stream after that start typing into the
daily wired chat box and drew will
answer questions as they come in for an
entire hour so once again subscribe get
your questions answered by drew tomorrow
2:30 p.m. Pacific 5:30 p.m. Eastern and
join the conversation you get all that
with the subscriptions that's pretty
awesome the annual subscription comes
along with this the leftist here is hot
or cold mug you will love it it is
enjoyable it makes you wiser smarter and
truer as a human being so check that out
you will you'll add yours to your life
I've heard ok I can't make that claim
it's not been verified by the FDA but I
hear that if you drink just once from
this tumbler then your life is is
strengthened that you actually you
actually double your muscle mass I don't
know if that's true or not I can tell
you before this I was just a weakling
and I drank from that and suddenly I'm a
stud so that's the way that works to
check that out 99 bucks a year and get
all of those aforementioned Gloria's is
cheaper than the monthly subscription or
if you just wanna listen later for free
go over to iTunes go over to SoundCloud
go over to YouTube we are the largest
fastest growing conservative show in the
nation
[Music]
all righty so I want to talk a little
bit more about Kevin Williamson here so
here is why this is a problem you may
think that Williamson is crazy
you may hate his viewpoints you may
think that Williamson is garbage
Kevin Williamson first of all is a very
good writer second of all Kevin
Williamson is wildly anti-trump when I
say he is wildly anti-trump I don't mean
he just opposed Trump in the election I
mean that he wrote a column when Trump
announced called the ape descends the
escalator I mean that this is a guy who
in his comps has called Donald Trump's
sons Uday and COO say okay he is not
subtle about his dislike for President
Trump and even he was not acceptable to
the left because he has he has a view on
abortion that is outside the mainstream
and as I say leftist views on abortion
which are inherently outside the
mainstream those are not outside the
mainstream according to the Atlantic
they're just fine again Peter Singer is
probably just fine for the Atlantic but
Kevin Williamson is not acceptable what
does this mean what this means that the
left is doing something really really
damaging to American discourse they're
shrinking the Overton Window can the
Overton Window it's a term that I
believe is originally used by the VP of
a think-tank
it was named after him the Overton
Window means the range of acceptable
discourse right so in any conversation
there's a range of acceptable discourse
there are people who you say are just
not acceptable to talk to you people who
for example say that black people are
innately inferior right that's it those
are people who are just not worth
talking to that is not acceptable
discourse now this does not mean they
they don't have a right to say what they
want to say they've a right to say
whatever they want to say it's the First
Amendment welcome to America that's fine
but I am NOT a moral relativist and I
don't believe that just because you have
a right to say something means that you
should say it or that everything that is
said is equal in value
okay so there's something called the
Overton Window which is the which is the
window of acceptable discourse or a
useful discourse but what the left has
done is they've shrunk the Overton
Window down to about pinprick size okay
so the Overton Window is now the space
of opinion between Bernie Sanders and
maybe Kamala Harris right that's
basically the level of acceptable
discourse between tana he codes
intersectional leftism and Bernie
Sanders socialist leftism everything in
between there is cool but if you're
outside that Overton Window then you are
unacceptable so what does this mean well
it means that the left has now separated
discourse not into three categories but
Institute so here are the three
categories I have for speech there is
the acceptable
there's the unacceptable right outside
the Overton Window and
in there is the acceptable stuff but I
disagree with it and there's lots of
that stuff
I'd say most discourse is stuff that I
disagree with but is within the Overton
Window what the left has done instead is
they have said there is the stuff we
agree with and then there is everything
else and everything else is unacceptable
so that means that Kevin Williamson is
now a deplorable it means that I am in a
plural it means that Barry Weiss a
columnist for The New York Times who I'm
sure voted for Hillary Clinton is it
deplorable it means that people like
Bret Stevens in Ross dude hat these
people are deplorable it means that
again Sam Harris is deplorable Sam
Harris and I disagree about a wide
variety of things but Sam Harris once
said on national television that Islam
is more dangerous religion than
Christianity and suddenly he was another
Brett Weinstein right a leftist
socialist college professor at Evergreen
State College who refused to not teach
on a day that the students said we only
want non-white teachers teaching he
showed up anyway and wanted to teach you
know that guy was declared an deplorable
because he was outside the acceptable
range of Windows right you say outside
the acceptable range of opinions so what
happens when you do this well what
happens when you do this is it means
that you are lumping in a bunch of
people you disagree with with
unacceptable bigots right so now Kevin
Williamson is in the same category
according to the left as Richard Spencer
I'm in the same category as Richard
Spencer you wonder why I get labeled the
Nazi by idiots on campus who don't know
the first thing about me
because I am not agreeing with them
therefore I am a Nazi it is that simple
I am not agreeing with them therefore I
am part of this basket of deplorable so
I am now outside the Overton Window and
I must be excluded for the from the
range of acceptable discourse this is
why President Trump is president this is
why for a short period of time the
alt-right was in the ascendance the
reason is because this leaves people who
have now been thrown out of the
acceptable range with a choice right we
can either say listen and we still think
there are three categories right not 2/3
we still think that you may disagree
with us but we're in the acceptable
category and so we refuse to allow you
to lump us in with people like Richard
Spencer we refuse to allow you to label
us a deplorable like some of the other
people you're labeling deplorable right
you can do that or you can say listen
screw you guys
you don't labeled everyone a Nazi so if
you're labeling me a Nazi I don't know
if I know I'm not a Nazi maybe the other
people you're labeling Nazis also are
not Nazis maybe all these bad people who
are already out here maybe they're out
here just because you don't like them
maybe you ought to give their views a
second look because
if you're labeling me the same way
you're labeling them if I get hit with
the same category that they're being hit
with then how do I know that you are
honest in your original appraisal of
those people and so there's a real
temptation on the part of people who
have been thrown out of the of the
acceptable category by the left to
simply band together and say listen
we're all in this together because we
hate you guys
because you guys threw us out we're out
here in the cold you throw us out of the
cabin and now it's snowing so we can
either argue amongst ourselves in the
snow or we can all band together and we
can try to break back into the cabin
right now that's sort of the idea that's
being that's being pushed here now the
moral thing to do would say listen we're
gonna try to break in the cabinet
without the people we think are bad we
have our own independent viewpoints I
buy own independent viewpoint and you
can try to throw me out of the range of
acceptable discourse but I refuse to
accept your label and I refuse to accept
that you're labeling me in the same way
that you label a bunch of people who
really are disgusting and who really do
have a disgusting views but the
temptation is going to be always a never
to simply say listen you've thrown us
all out aligned to the alliances of
convenience if you have declared war on
us well we're not gonna we're not gonna
play by the Marquess of Queensberry
rules you declare war on us we'll take
the allies we can get and we'll fight
back against you the left has been
counting on the virtue of conservatives
to keep them from making common cause
with truly garbage people but that makes
no sense if you call conservatives
garbage people and then you say yes but
you really should continue to separate
yourself off from the actual garbage
people you can't have it both ways if
we're garbage then you have to expect us
not to act virtuous right this is you
want to know why we're entering into a
tribal routine here why we're getting
closer and closer to political tribalism
that is going to end poorly for all
involved the reason is because the left
has created the anti left tribe okay
that's what's happened this is why this
is why Donald Trump was successful he
didn't campaign as a conservative the
campaign is an anti left fighter and a
lot of people said okay fine well if
he's against them I'm with him this is
how you generate that if the left really
wanted to have a serious conversation
they wanted to prevent this sort of
tribalism all they have to do is
recognize that there are people with
whom they disagree that they will still
allow to be part of the discourse but I
don't mean people like David Frum who
would pretend to disagree with them but
really agree with them on a broad swath
of policies if they continue along these
lines they're gonna they're really
cruisin for a bruisin they're really
cruising there's gonna be a backlash and
it's going to be uncontrollable
and they're not gonna like the impact
they're already not liking the impact is
the backlash is already underway okay so
now I want to talk a little bit about
some insanity that's happening in Great
Britain because this is truly crazy so
apparently there's been a wild upswing
in the amount of murder in London well
that's not a tremendous shock
considering that the demographics of
London have changed that the policing in
London has changed wildly that the Mayor
of London Sadiq Khan is really terrible
at his job but the murder rate in London
now outstrips the murder rate in New
York which is pretty incredible actually
right the murder rate in Britain has
always been extraordinarily low this is
why when people say well you know you
ban guns in Britain that's why the
murder rate is low the murder rate was
low before the bans on guns and the
murder rate in Britain was always quite
low but here is here is what it says
according to today online on Thursday
April 5th five teenagers were stabbed in
an hour and a half before sunset
including a boy of 13 all these attacks
took place in London over the past week
part of an apparent spike in violence in
the British capital after a long period
of steady declines in violent crime
the city has averaged in excess of three
killings a week so far this year more
than 50 people have been killed in
London since the start of 2018 the total
for all of 2017 a year when the city
suffered multiple deadly terrorist
attacks was 116 criminologists have
expressed caution about drawing
conclusions from only a few months
figures but if the uptick continues it
will amount to London's highest level of
violence in more than a decade a year
with 200 homicides for a city of 8.5
million people would be far from a
shocking high in the u.s. New York City
had 292 murders last year according to
the 2018 police commissioner's report
that was a record low
but right now London's murder rate is
outstripping the murder rate in New York
City which is again a pretty incredible
thing so I do love what they are now
talking about in London they're not
talking about banning knives no joke so
they're using the exact same logic they
used about guns and now they're applying
it to knives so Sadiq Khan has announced
a broad new knife control policy
designed to keep quote/unquote weapons
of war out of the hands of it wanders
looking to cause others harm the UK
Parliament is considering bills that
restrict the manufacture and purchase of
kitchen cooking knives because they have
points on them because they're pointy
things
so I guess machetes would still be okay
like the one that that guy used a couple
of years ago that that Muslim terrorists
used to chop down an actual British
soldier on the streets of on the streets
of London
that'll still be okay because as we all
know machetes aren't really dangerous
like him from every horror film we know
machetes aren't dangerous only knives
are dangerous but they're going to start
determining how exactly knives are
distributed the tough immediate measures
involve an incredible police crackdown a
ban on home deliveries of knives and
acid and expanding law enforcement stop
and search powers so the police may stop
anyone they believed to be a threat or
planning a knife or acid attack Khan
announced Friday the city has created a
quote violent crime task force 120
officers tasked with rooting out knife
wielding individuals in public spaces
and is pumping nearly 50 million dollars
into the Metropolitan Police Department
so they can better armed themselves
against knife attacks
he's also empowering the Met Police to
introduce targeted patrols of extra stop
and search powers for areas
worst-affected according to a statement
now one of the what's what's really kind
of hilarious here is that one of the
reasons that the crime rate is going up
is because Khan is responsible for
according to Emily's inaudi at the Daily
wire for decreasing the number of stop
and searches having previously declared
the tactic racist and potentially
Islamophobic so in other words got rid
of stop and stop and frisk in London
saying that it was targeting too many
young Muslim guys and then the crime
rate went up and now he's gonna target
everyone it's not really clear what
they're gonna use in London to cut their
food anymore if you can't get a home
delivery of a knife and if you're not
allowed to carry at home how do you
actually get the knife from the
department store home Parliament is set
to take up heavy knife control
legislation when it resumes this week
the UK government is expected to
introduce a ban on online knife sales
and home knife deliveries so now you
have to go to a store to purchase a
knife maybe it's have a license to
purchase a knife you have to have to be
what if the Accu linaria specialist they
declare illegal to possess the zombie
knives and knuckle dusters in private
zombie knives are those defined as being
manufactured for the purpose of being
used as a person-to-person weapon and
banned sales of caustic materials to
anyone under the age of 18 of course
that won't really stop anything since
most of these acid attacks that have
been occurring are occurring among
people who are late teenagers or older
London seen a dramatic uptick in murder
rates of course so again it ain't about
the knives folks maybe you ought to look
at the people who are wielding the
knives
maybe you ought to be looking at the
people who are actually performing the
acid attacks but since we're not allowed
to do that we're gonna crackdown our
knives and then we'll crack down on
fists and then we'll crack down on any
blunt object in your home you want to be
allowed to have blunt objects soon we'll
end up all sitting in blank room
with no furniture because anything can
be used maybe baby pillows but nobody
can use pillows for suffocation so
eventually we all just walk him around
like John Travolta in the bubble boy
because that presumably will stop crime
not actually targeting criminals pretty
amazing stuff but demonstrates what
happens when an entire civilization
loses their mind and stops targeting
criminality and starts instead
pretending that the tools of criminality
are more important than the criminals
themselves
ok time for of a couple of things that I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like so on the way home
yesterday in the car it was a long drive
and so everyone was asleep and so that's
a good time to listen to musical theater
because you actually get a story told to
you well one of my favorite musicals is
of course Pippin and one of the best
numbers from Pippin is corner of the sky
here's what it sounds like in the new
Broadway production is just tremendous I
believe it's on tour now if it's not
then it was recently but the production
is really really good it's not for
children obviously it's pg-13 and up but
this song is just great
[Music]
everything has its season
thing has its time
show me a reason and also show me your I
can't spit on the windowsill children
fit in the snow so why do I feel I don't
feel anywhere I go rivers belong
where they can round
he goes
so this show won best Tony best best
best musical Tony in the 1970s and it's
really first-rate one of the things
that's fascinating about this show is
that the whole show is about a guy who
has these wide world aspirations for
changing the world and making a dent in
the world and all this stuff and it's
about him learning that you can that may
be the best way to make a dent in the
world is just by living a life where you
bring up your wife and kids and it's a
pretty pretty amazing message that comes
out of Broadway particularly because
Broadway is so far to the left but it's
it's an important message nonetheless so
check out Pippin if you ever have a
chance it's really it's really great
okay a couple of other things that I
like so
apparently Bill Maher over the weekend
defended Laura Ingraham Laura Ingraham
of course was victim of a boycott by a
bunch of leftist because she said
something quasi mean to a parkland
student which are not allowed to do and
Bill Maher comes out he says listen I
don't like Laura Ingraham but this is
stupid good for Bill Maher I want to
defend Laura Ingraham I know that sounds
ridiculous but it has to do with the
Parkland kids and guns and free speech
now I think those kids did a great thing
they put this issue in a place we've
never had it before and I wish them
success but you know if you're gonna be
out there in the arena and make
yourselves the champions of this cause
people are gonna have the right I think
to argue back here's what she she
tweeted David hog rejected by four
colleges because he put that up there
because of course we have to share
everything to which he applied and
whined about it okay maybe you shouldn't
say that about a seventeen-year-old but
again he is in the arena and then he
calls for a boycott of her sponsors now
what what is really is that American to
coffee explain something because I and
he complains about bullying that's
bullying boycott job once it is wrong
you should we do this by team you should
do it by principle good for a good firm
are good from our I mean what Mars
saying here is exactly correct and again
you know Mars one of these guys who
knows because he has been thrown out of
the left for his failures to abide by
the window of acceptable discourse right
he said some things
the left doesn't like on occasion and
this is because particularly that Islam
and this has made him a target of the
left the more the left throws people out
and calls for boycotts against them and
the more they are destroying their own
credibility even with the people who
supposedly like them okay time for a
couple of things that I hate okay thing
that I hate number one so there's a
story out of Bradenton Florida and this
is supposed to be some sort of grand
civil rights issue apparently there's a
seventeen-year-old named Lizzy Martin
and she was told by the principal of her
school or the school district that she
needed to put band-aids on her nipples
why because she showed up to school in a
gray Calvin Klein shirt without wearing
any bra and so they tried to make her
put on a second t-shirt and then they
said well maybe you should just cover up
your nipples and she said we went to the
clinic and the nurse gave me band-aids
in there and she told me to X out my
nipples she followed the command saying
she felt she had no other options her
mother told the outlet that school dean
made a big deal about it said this was a
shirt that was unisex that was too big
that was not form-fitting she said there
was a double standard than a male with
excessive breast tissue wouldn't be
asked to confine the movement of his
chest okay this is the stupidest crap
ever
he's a 17 year old girl she's in a class
a bunch of seven-year-old boys if you
really believe there's a 17 year old
girl with half a grain of intelligence
on planet earth who doesn't know exactly
what she's doing when she wears no bra
to class with a bunch of 17 year old
boys he got another thing coming this
doesn't mean boys should sexually harass
obviously not it doesn't mean that boys
should say anything or do anything to
her none of that is the case but if you
think it's not distracting to boys when
there are girls walking around with
their nipples showing you're out of your
mind look what are we supposed to
pretend that human nature doesn't exist
now is what we are supposed to pretend
and are we supposed to pretend that the
17 year old girl doesn't know that human
nature exists are we set end this is a
thing okay that most schools have dress
codes the reason they have dress codes
is precisely to avoid this sort of
situation where boys are being
distracted by girls and girls are being
distracted by boys
honestly you want the best thing for
girls in school really there's been
studies to prove this the best things
for girls in school are sex segregated
classes okay like when I went to high
school I went to an Orthodox Jewish high
school there was a boy school there was
a girls school girls and sex segregated
classes do better they do better not
it's not for the benefit of the boys
that this happens
girls do better why because girls have
the
weird idea that boys want them to be
stupid and sexualized and so they played
to those stereotypes but if they're with
a bunch of girls then they're just there
for the academics but again if a 17 year
old girl wears something completely
inappropriate to school and she's
distracting the other students I fail to
see how this is completely like what the
school district did that was so
unbelievably wrong here they probably
shouldn't told her to go put like
band-aids on her nipples but they should
have called up her parents and say you
know mom bring her a sweatshirt or they
should have had one of the teachers say
okay here's a sweatshirt put on the
sweatshirt but again like if you're
gonna take this logic to its full
extreme presumably what you would say is
that you should walk around topless and
that should be no problem everybody
should basically say okay no problem you
know what it's just listen if a boy
walks around topless
it wouldn't be then you wouldn't have a
problem with that yes because boys and
girls are different here first of all
you don't want boys walking around
topless either but but to pretend that a
dude walking around topless is the same
thing as a woman walking around topless
in American society is fully crazy it's
fully crazy hey but I guess we have to
completely pretend that again reality
doesn't exist in human nature doesn't
exist and so it's some sort of grand sin
that the police that the that the school
district thought that a girl should
actually cover up her nipples in a class
with boys what stupidity what stupidity
okay other things that I hate so last
week I made it sound like the stuff on
Clark case in Sacramento was a little
more clear-cut than it was and I want to
correct myself on that because I think
that it's important that we get as much
of the truth about this as possible so
here is the actual tape of what happened
Stephon Clark so here is first of all
the introduction to that tape police
responded to reports of a broken window
David French over national view
describes it and when you watch all the
released footage you can see the initial
response is pretty calm and casual two
officers politely knock on a door they
asked permission to search her backyard
they find nothing and then they walk
back to the street meanwhile a
helicopter overhead spots a person
trying to break into a car and then
jumping a fence and moving to a
neighboring house where he looks in a
car window and that person is Stephon
Clark so he is it in the middle of
criminal activity and then you run this
to his grandparents house there's
nothing visible in his hands at that
time the police run to the house they
spot Clark in the driveway and they yell
hey show me your hands stop stop
and Clark instead of obeying flees to
the back of the house the officers
pursue and they around the corner of the
house and one says show me your hands
gun okay so they think that he has gone
they retreat behind the corner for
roughly one or two seconds then they
round the corner again one officer yells
show me your hands gun gun gun and they
start firing and twenty seconds later
he's dead so the encounter from yelling
hey - Clark - firing the first shot
takes approximately 17 seconds here is
what it looks like
on the body cams okay so as you can see
is really difficult to see what's going
on there it's very difficult to see and
so I wouldn't want to be unfair to the
officers by saying that they went in
there with the intent to kill or
anything like this but does this look
like something negligent to me it looks
like I mean that the amount of time that
he's given to respond is very short now
should he have immediately obeyed the
officers command yes I mean this is rule
number one when an officer tells you to
do something you obey the command also
should she have been breaking into cars
probably not this is not a good idea
however that said does that mean that
officers are completely free from FAL
ability in these sorts of situations the
guy was unarmed he was unarmed okay and
when he comes back around they say show
me your hands gun gun gun it the I mean
you can hear it it's right on the back
of it it's not show me your hands gun
gun gun right is show me your hands gun
gun gun so they're gonna chance to give
him a chance to respond and and I think
David French get to this raises before
you object and tell me that routine
encounters can into escalate I know that
but what I'm questioning are
probabilities in perspective here are
some questions if it's dark police are
sprinting and flashlights are shaking
what are the chances that the cops first
assessment the suspect had a gun or
wrong what was the reasonable risk of
backing off and continuing to get strong
verbal commands rather than immediately
moving from cover to an exposed position
and opening fire what are the
possibility that the suspect hadn't
heard the commands and all there's some
evidence that he may have had earbuds in
also what's the background level of risk
here Sacramento hasn't seen a cop shot
and killed in the line of duty for
almost 20 years and it's true the cops
have seconds to make life-and-death
decisions but you know who else has like
that who has just a couple of seconds to
figure that out is the suspect so if you
don't give the suspect a chance to
respond then what exactly are you
supposed to do this doesn't mean that
these cops are gonna go to jail
sort of suggested last week it's
possible that they won't it's possible
the people will find this their story
convincing or at least they will find it
justifiable or at least excusable but
there are some problems of training I
think among some of our police officers
and certainly this does raise questions
about deadly use of force by police
officers and whether they should be so
quick on the trigger in some of these
particular situations okay so I just
wanted to clarify all of that because I
don't want to get any of the facts wrong
by the way there's another correction I
think I have to make from last week as
well and that was on the show last week
I'd mentioned the YouTube shooter and I
think I'd suggested that she was Muslim
I said of course that her religion had
nothing to do with the shooting because
she just seems like a crazy person
apparently she was Baha'i it doesn't
really change much because I said
religion had nothing to do with it but
just to correct the record I want to
make sure I get as many facts correct as
I can on the show and by the way folks
you have all but you all have my email
addresses be Shapiro daily wear comm if
you hear me make a mistake on the air
please let me know so I can correct it
on the air so that I'm not screwing
things up all righty so I think we've
run out of time we'll do a federalist
paper tomorrow probably sometime later
this week because we've run out of time
but we'll see you here then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alec singhara audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018